à retenir du week-end sportif le pied de
nez d'alain prost qui a remporté le
grand prix d'italie de formule 1 sur le
circuit de monza ce qui le place en
excellente position pour empêcher un
nouveau titre de champion du monde des
pilotes de formule 1 alain prost en
délicatesse avec ses employeurs mclaren
depuis qu'il a annoncé son transfert
chez ferrari ce qui a fait d'ailleurs la
joie des supporters italiens tôt démarre
c'est certainement le tournant de la
saison ayrton senna en tête du grand
prix d'italie casse son moteur et
abandonne
alain prose alors second passe eelv a
remporté sa 39e victoire une victoire
acquise avec un peu de chance c'est vrai
mais sans cela il n'aurait jamais pu
gagner à la régulière
c'était je pense impossible même s'il
revenait à peu sur lui un moment où la
voiture sale et j'en ai fait un peu
mieux mais au niveau moteur sinon rien à
voir je pense que c'est c'est pour ça
que c'est un peu frustrant après une
victoire même si c'est un point d'avancé
encore très confiant tout reste possible
tout reste possible d'autant plus que
senna avant son abandon avait réussi une
belle course après un excellent départ
fidèle à son habitude il est resté 45
tours en tête comptant jusqu'à 22
secondes d'avancé sur ses poursuivants
mais derrière prost réagi parti 4e il
dépasse tout d'abord son futur équipier
mais également de sel puis l'autre
pilote de ferrari
gerard berg r il est alors second puis
premier avec la mise à pied
bertone senna alain prost impose donc de
van bergen qui marque ses premiers
points cette année
thierry boutsen riccardo patrese et jean
alesi aux championnats du monde le
français compte désormais 20 points
d'avancé sur le brésilien pour la plus
grande joie des tifosi qui prennent
cette victoire comme le premier cadeau
du petit français
puis victoire